you don't need hundreds of bar tools to
make a great cocktail but I'm gonna show
you some of the basics this is a bar
spoon this measures five mils or
essentially a dash most obvious thing
it's used for is stirring you want to
make the spoon do all the work for you
so you just rest it between your two
fingers like that and then just roll it
around and then you don't get the ice
shards and all those ice creams popping
out and then lastly you can actually use
it just to muddle your flavors down a
couple of mint leaves in there you put
the back of the bar spoon at the bottom
press it down and just give it a little
twist
not as aggressive as a muddler that
serves the same purpose now our next
bottle is a muddler
the idea is to press down the fruit
breaking the fruit up and making it into
a puree the technique to it is pressing
down and turning break it up until it's
a puree and then it's ready to be made
into a cocktail now we have a Hawthorne
strainer you put your finger in the
middle of the strainer and then you grab
the breast of the strainer you're gonna
do is simply strain your drink into the
cocktail also a great thing about the
strainer if you pull the coil off you
put the coil into the shaker drop it in
now if you've got an egg white or
anything that kind of foams up that coil
in there is gonna whip up all the
flavors and the creams and then you have
a lovely aerated and foamy cocktail now
there's so many bar tools on the market
nowadays but at least if you have these
tools you can make yourself a blinding
cocktail there's more cocktail videos
like this at the GQ channel